tote und verletzte in halle auf offener
straße werden zwei menschen erschossen
ziel des angriffs war offenbar eine
vollbesetzte synagoge
ich sehe ein land in dem sich risse auf
tun sagt bundespräsident steinmeier beim
festakt in leipzig 30 jahre nach dem
friedlichen protesten dort und ankara
macht ernst im nordosten syriens startet
die türkei ihre militäroffensive gegen
kurdische milizen
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
ein bedrückender nachrichten tag meine
damen und herren guten abend norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport
gründerfamilie was für ein albtraum in
halle in sachsen anhalt mindestens ein
unbekannter in kampfmontur versucht
offenbar in einem mit 70 bis 80
gläubigen gefüllte synagoge einzudringen
in der nähe werden zwei menschen
erschossen ein verdächtiger wird
festgenommen
die polizei fahndet noch nach möglichen
mittätern
die behörden forderten die menschen auf
ihre wohnungen nicht zu verlassen
der angriff ereignete sich am mittag im
norden von halle im eher beschaulichen
paulusviertel dort sind die synagoge und
ein jüdischer friedhof und es gibt einen
angriff auf einen döner imbiss ganz in
der nähe auch aus landsberg östlich von
halle werden später schüsse gemeldet
david sauer und florian cossen die
ereignisse zusammen wie ein soldat ist
er ausgerüstet mit helm kampfanzug und
gewehr mit einer helmkamera zeichnete er
alles aus dem fenster filmt ein anwohner
wie der täter sich seinen weg frei
schiesst ein augenzeuge
und dann hat er es ist kurz beschreiben
was wirst du mit helm kleidung also
komplett bewaffnet balladen oder
friedhofsmauer sie haben auch
explosionen gehört genau das ziel des
angriffs die synagoge am jom kippur tag
dem höchsten feiertag des judentums ist
sie voll besetzt
die menschen im innern verbarrikadieren
die türen retten so womöglich viele
leben
ein weiterer augenzeuge ich wollte heute
straßen dann muss ich erst mal in
deckung gehen
das neue will christa
auf der flucht erschießen der oder die
täter einen mann in einem döner-imbiss
dem fonds hat halle verlassen und die
polizei konnte außer halbfinale ein
fahrzeug dann dingfest machen und einen
täter festnehmen
doch die polizei fahndet weiter wie hier
im etwa 15 kilometer entfernten
landsberg panzerfahrzeuge und schwer
bewaffnete spezialkräfte sind vor ort
hubschrauber unterstützen die aktion
zu den näheren umständen dort ist aber
nichts bekannt etwa 50 kilometer südlich
bei version gibt es am frühen abend
einen unfall in dem wagen werden laut
berichten viele waffen gefunden
möglicherweise sei es sogar ein täter am
steuer noch ist unklar wie viele täter
ist tatsächlich gibt und ob noch jemand
auf der flucht ist
die polizei kontrolliert derzeit den
verkehr auch in anderen bundesländern
und die grenzen ins ausland
die bundesanwaltschaft in karlsruhe hat
die ermittlungen an sich gezogen
es gebe anhaltspunkte für einen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund
annegret oster in halle wie gefährlich
ist die lage im moment noch die polizei
hat vor ungefähr einer dreiviertel
stunde die akute gefährdungslage die es
heute den ganzen tag über gab aufgehoben
das heißt die bürger können wieder
unbesorgt auf die straße gehen
den ganzen tag über seit heute mittag
galt bitte zu hause bleiben
ansonsten ist noch vieles unklar fest
steht nur eine verdächtige ein mannes
festgenommen worden ob das tatsächlich
der täter oder einer der täter ist ist
unser ganz genau
auch noch ob es wirklich der einzige
täter war oder ob es weitere täter
ergibt die noch auf der flucht sind
der angriff galt einer seiner bis 70 bis
80 menschen die situation dort muss
dramatisch gewesen sein was wissen sie
darüber
der vorsitzende der jüdischen gemeinde
hier der mit etwa 70 bis 80 anderen
gläubigen in der synagoge war während
dieses anschlages hat sich zu wort
gemeldet und hat von dramatischen szenen
berichtet
von innen hätten sie eine
überwachungskamera gehabt die einen
bewaffneten mann in kampfmontur gezeigt
habe der versucht hätte ein zu trinken
sie haben von die türen von innen
verriegelt und sind so tatsächlich alle
unverletzt geblieben ist man kann sich
vorstellen wie schrecklich das gewesen
sein muss ob das in verbindung steht mit
dem höchsten jüdischen feiertag der
heute begangen wird jom kippur ist
unklar wie eben vieles alle anderen
dieser schrecklichen tat auch die
polizei hält sich sehr bedeckt wir
werden weiter berichten dankeschön für
den moment an bewusster nach halle
der anschlag auf die synagoge hat große
bestürzung ausgelöst quer durch die
gesellschaft bei parteien und kirchen
bis hin zum uno-generalsekretär
innenminister seehofer spricht
inzwischen von einer antisemitischen tat
wenig geschafft was die reaktionen
zusammen
die nachrichten von halle gehen um die
welt
das europäische parlament gedenkt der
opfer mit einer schweigeminute
jüdische gotteshäuser schützen
das entsetzen führt zu mehr
sicherheitsmaßnahmen in mehreren
bundesländern in berlin verabreden sich
politiker für den späteren abend hier
vor der jüdischen synagoge im herzen der
stadt um haltung zu zeigen gegen
antisemitismus in deutschland ganz klar
ist dass auch die bürgerinnen bürger
unseres landes jüdischen glaubens sicher
sein können dass wir mit unseren ganzen
herzen beiden sind und deswegen die
ganze solidarität übermitteln die ob es
überhaupt möglich ist das ist eine
schlimme nachricht an diesem tag und ich
glaube nicht nur ich sondern sehr viele
andere sind schwer erschüttert auch der
außenminister begründet sein mitgefühl
er schreibt auf twitter dass am
versöhnungsfest jom kippur auf eine
synagoge geschossen wird trifft uns ins
herz
wir alle müssen gegen
antisemitismus in unserem land vorgehen
die meldungen von halle platzten am
mittag in die regierungspressekonferenz
in der es eigentlich um ganz andere
dinge ging das ist eine schreckliche
nachrichten aus halle und ich hoffe sehr
dass die polizei den täter die täter
möglichst schnell fassen kann und das
vor allem auch bis dahin kein weiterer
mensch in gefahr kommen
bundeskanzlerin merkel spricht den
angehörigen der opfer ihr tiefes
mitgefühl aus sie hat sich von
innenminister seehofer bei die lage
informieren lassen
der gibt vor wenigen minuten bekannt die
aktuelle erkenntnislage erlaube es noch
nicht die tat abschließend einzuordnen
die behörden wollen morgen über die
ermittlungen informieren
gleich nach diesen nachrichten gibt es
ein zdf spezial todesschüsse vor
synagoge amok alarm in halle um 1920 und
jederzeit informieren können sie sich
natürlich auch online auf heute.de in
einem live blog finden sie alle
aktuellen entwicklungen zum nachlesen
wenige kilometer vom tatort halle ist
leipzig eigentlich ein ort der
feierlichkeiten heute die stadt steht im
zeichen eines historischen moments am
vormittag würdigt hier bundespräsident
steinmeier den 9
oktober 89 als großen tag für die
deutsche geschichte
vor genau 30 jahren wagen sich 70.000
menschen zur montagsdemonstration auf
die straße so viele wie noch niemals
zuvor ihre rufe keine gewalt wir sind
das volk die bewaffnete staatsmacht
lässt sie gewähren und die friedliche
revolution in der ddr nimmt ihren lauf
stefan kech
christoph schmidt erlitt vor 30 jahren
am 9 oktober ein schweres trauma er
stand damals zufällig in der ersten
reihe der demonstranten
voller angst heute zu sterben er ging
davon aus dass geschossen werden würde
das gefühl 70.000 leute schieben von
hinten und direkt vor mir steht eine
schützenkette mit einer waffe die ich
kannte das hat in mir ein angst trauma
ausgelöst was ich leider wirklich bis
heute mit mir rumschleppen
aber heute will er seine geschichte
erzählen als zeitzeuge geschichten die
deutsche geschichte geschrieben haben
ausgangs- und mittelpunkt der bewegung
die nikolaikirche immer montags gingen
nach den friedensgebeten die menschen
für ihre freiheit auf die straße
christel trainings hat den alten aufruf
zur großdemo heute dabei und der wird
eben darauf hingewiesen dass keine
gewalt das kein und die polizeiketten
durchbrechen soll und dass keine
personen angegriffen werden sondern dass
alles friedlich ablaufen 70.000 hielten
sich an diesen aufruf sie forderten
friedlich das ende der ddr diktatur
vier wochen später fiel die mauer
bundespräsident steinmeier bezeichnet
diesen neunter oktober als großen tag
der deutschen geschichte
doch bei aller feierlichkeit auch viel
nachdenken
ich sehe ein land in dem sich risse auf
thun risse die sich auch in
wahlergebnissen wider spiegeln aber mehr
noch in der art und weise wie wir
übereinander und wie wir über dieses
land reden zur stunde bereiten die
leipziger ihr lichterfest vor tausende
kerzen sollen am abend den weg der
demonstranten von 1989 nachzeichnen
das lichterfest wurde nicht abgesagt die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen aber erhöhen
thomas bärsch wie ist die stimmung an
diesem besonderen tag für leipzig und
welche rolle spielt das was in halle
passiert ist ja die stadt leipzig ist
seit dem frühen vormittag voller
menschen alle waren auf den straßen das
thema halle spielt natürlich eine rolle
nicht alle leipziger hatten sofort
zyklus auf die nachrichten wer ein handy
hatte wurde auch oft mal fragen wie ist
die sicherheitslage
ob sich viele leipziger davon abhalten
ließen heute herzukommen ist nicht zu
sagen von hier aus jetzt es sieht nicht
so aus es liegt auch daran dass der tag
wirklich ein sehr besonderer vielleicht
sich ist eben weil er damals ich endlich
blieb wovon die landzunge die damals
mitgelaufen sind eben nicht ausgehen
können
die veranstaltung hier begann mit einer
schweigeminute für die opfer von halle
und es legte sich über diesen platz mit
den tausenden leipzigern wirklich eine
sekundenlange sehr bedrückende stille
vom lichterfest aus leipzig thomas
barsch war das vielen dank am nachmittag
kam dann auch noch diese nachricht trotz
der massiven internationalen kritik hat
die türkei ihre militäroffensive in
syrien begonnen
man gehe mit luftangriffen und
artilleriefeuer sagte ein sprecher
ziel der operation ist das von der
kurden miliz epg kontrollierte gebiet im
nordosten syriens die türkei bezeichnet
die beats die noch bis vor kurzem an der
seite der usa gegen denise gekämpft
hatte
als terroristen thomas gell berichtet
die ersten kampfflugzeuge staaten gegen
16 uhr ortszeit vom flughafen in die
abag ihr es ist der beginn einer
militäroffensive mit der präsident
erdogan seine sicherheitszone
durchsetzen will eine art puffer zu den
bewaffneten kurden milizen der gpg die
als terroristen bezeichnet
auf twitter vermeldet er unsere absicht
ist es den terror korridor an der
türkischen grenze zu beseitigen und der
region frieden und ruhe zu bringen
unterstützt von der artillerie hat die
türkische luftwaffe ziele auf einer
länge von 120 kilometern auf syrischem
boden nahe der grenze bombardiert
noch ist unklar die beiden erdogan in
das syrische gebiet vorrücken will ich
wünsche unseren soldaten viel erfolg und
küsste sie auf die stirn sagt der
präsident als oberster befehlshaber in
den istanbuler teestuben ist der
einmarsch das thema viele unterstützen
diese operation an der türkei mehr
sicher okay eine sicherheitszone kann es
geben aber in ein land einzumarschieren
das nicht unsere nicht klug die von
kurden dominierten sürig demokratischen
kräfte sds haben die generalmobilmachung
verkündet rauchwolken auch auf der
türkischen seite auf die offensive haben
die kurden mit mörsergranaten
geantwortet
nach washington dort wird der streit
über ein mögliches
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump immer heftiger das weiße haus
verweigert jegliche kooperation mit dem
kongress was die herausgabe von
dokumenten angeht oder zeugenaussagen
von regierungsmitarbeitern die
oppositionellen demokraten sind empört
der präsident stehen nicht über dem
gesetz er werde zur verantwortung
gezogen
der klimaschutz in deutschland wird
gesetz zum ersten mal wird verbindlich
festgeschrieben wie viel treibhausgas
eingespart werden muss dass klimaschutz
gesetz schreibt vor wie viel co2 in
einzelnen bereichen künftig höchstens
ausgestoßen werden darf etwa von der
industrie von gebäuden der
landwirtschaft oder der energieerzeugung
das ziel 2030 sollen es 55 prozent
weniger co2 seien als 1990
ebenfalls beschlossen wurde das
klimaschutzprogramm darin steht unter
anderem die einführung des viel
diskutierten co2 preises patricia
wiedemeier berichtet das sei kein
wirkliches paket höchstens ein klima
häppchen die ganze woche schon
demonstrieren klimaaktivisten von
exchange in rebellion in berlin fordern
weitergehen
massnahmen zufrieden dagegen die
bundesregierung bis zur letzten minute
hatte man um das gesetz der
umweltministerin gerungen
vorgesehen ist nun dass jeder minister
verantwortlich ist für die co2
einsparungen in seinem bereich ab jetzt
sind alle ministerien klimaschutz
ministerien die zeit wo die
umweltministerin bitte bitte gesagt hat
und den anderen ständig auf die füße
treten musste diese zeit ist jetzt
endgültig vorbei
erstmals legt die bundesregierung
klimaschutzziele gesetzlich fest ein
expertengremium soll das kontrollieren
der opposition reicht das nicht
wenn es sanktionen hätte und harte szene
könnte ein mechanismus sein
aber teile dieser cenis und dem
klimaschutzgesetz gezogen worden
beschlossen wurde jetzt auch das heftig
diskutierte klimaschutzprogramm danach
soll unter anderem der co2 ausstoß einen
preis bekommen zehn euro pro tonne weit
unter dem was wissenschaftler empfohlen
haben bahnfahren billiger fliegen teurer
werden der verkehrsbereich das größte
problem
dort wird wenig ambitioniert gehandelt
jeder weiß doch man muss den
öffentlichen nahverkehr schneller
ausbauen
man muss ihnen deutlich billiger machen
so dass die leute den anreiz haben
umzusteigen weitere gesetze aus dem
klima paket sollen folgen im laufe des
jahres die kritik von den demonstranten
vor dem kanzleramt sie wird bleiben und
wir schauen noch nach schweden auf die
entscheidung der königlichen akademie
der nobelpreis für chemie geht an die
väter der lithium-ionen-batterie den
briten stanley whiting ham den japaner
akira hoshino und den us-amerikaner mit
dem schönen namen john be good enough
der wissenschaftler wurde in jena
geboren und ist mit 97 jahren der
älteste nobelpreisträger überhaupt die
lithium ionen batterie macht uns alle
mobil sie liefert energie für
smartphones laptops und elektroauto und
damit sind wir beim fußball-länderspiel
ich habe eben deinen text auf meinem
teleporter gesehen deswegen war ich
verwirrt länderspiel deutschland
argentinien oder könnte es heißen
geteiltes leid ist halbes leid
denn nicht nur bundestrainer löw muss
auf viele stammspieler verzichten auch
sein gegenüber scaroni der tritt heute
abend in dortmund mit einer
rumpfmannschaft an
leonel scaroni hat sorgen der
nationaltrainer soll einen umbruch im
argentinischen fussball vornehmen dann
aber gehen die spieler aus
ein haufen unbekannter auch
weltfußballer lionel messi wird fehlen
wegen seiner sperre
trotzdem sind wir zuversichtlich sehr
zuversichtlich wäre paolo dyballa der
stürmer von juventus turin nicht
mitgekommen scaroni hätte nur noch
nachwuchsspieler für dieses prestige
duell jugend forscht für argentiniens
fußball zukunft für uns ist das ein
wichtiger test ich erwarte ein deutsches
team das historisches neue situation
fünf jahre nach dem wm-triumph von
maracana müssen beide trainer heute in
dortmund improvisieren zur turn- wm in
stuttgart da hat das russische
herrenteam heute nachmittag
titelverteidiger china entzaubert und
ist nach 28 jahren auf den
weltmeisterthron zurückgekehrt unbändige
freude bei russlands turnern team
weltmeister nach einem äußerst
spannenden wettkampf die favorisierten
chinesen haben lange die nase vorn
erst dieser fehler am letzten gerät
eröffnet den russen die chance auf gold
sie halten dem druck stand
russlands star turner nikita nagorny
geht als letzter ans gerät und auch er
mit einer nahezu perfekten übung china
geschlagen russland ist team-weltmeister
japan freut sich über bronze
ja und die deutschen turner die hat mir
das finale der besten acht verpasst aber
die olympia quali geschafft das ist doch
was
danke schön ja noch die lottozahlen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 2 12 22 32 40 45 und
die superzahl 8 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter morgen ist nochmal
wechselhaft zum wochenende wird sauber
melder mehr gleich von christa stirb
claus kleber begrüßt sie um kurz vor 10
im heute journal
wir wünschen ihnen einen friedlichen
abend und sind morgen wieder da wenn sie
mögen und hier kommt jetzt das zdf
spezial zur halle auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
sehr guten abend jetzt bis zum
wochenende breitet sich das azorenhoch
so langsam zu uns aus aber erstmal nur
in den süden mit sonne und wärme im
norden bleibt es bei tiefen trug vor
allem am freitag regnerisch und bewirkt
und bis dahin hat ohnehin das
wechselhafte wetter noch überall die
oberhand zwar werden die schauer heute
nach weniger in der zweiten nachthälfte
verstärken sie sich von südwesten her
aber schon wieder etwas dem hinter
dauerregen an den alpen lässt nach
dazu gibt es fünf bis zehn grad und
einen frischen südwestrand der morgen
etwas zulegt mit stürmischen böen auf
den bergen und an der see und
dementsprechend schnell ziehen auch die
wolken also es wird wirklich wechselhaft
regenschauer sind überall zwischendurch
mal möglich wobei der schwerpunkt
wahrscheinlich vormittags über der mitte
und dem südosten liegt und nachmittags
dann im nordwesten aber allzuviel kommt
da morgen insgesamt nicht vom himmel
außer vielleicht mal in einem kurzen
gewitter
das ganze gibt es bei höchstwerten
zwischen 11 und 17 grad morgen aber ab
dann wird es stück für stück wärmer die
milde luft kommt aus dem süden so dass
am sonntag im südwesten ein sommertag
mit 26 grad möglich ist bis dieser
goldene oktober aber im norden ankommt
wie gesagt das dauert ein bisschen hier
noch teils stürmisch und regnerisch